yup it gets cold in the winter but this
cold whatever happened to all this
global warming business the four-foot
snowdrift outside my door is apparently
a skeptic but counterintuitive as it may
seem extreme weather events like deep
freeze are believed to be the result of
global warming here's how it works
as the earth warms the Arctic heats up
almost twice as fast as the rest of the
planet a phenomenon known as Arctic
amplification the warming lowers the
temperature differential between the
cooler arctic air and the warmer air to
the south
pushing cooler air into North America
causing temperatures to plummet so while
the current weather is bone-chilling
cold globally we're heating up with
global temperatures up almost a full
degrees Celsius over the 20th century
average don't expect these spells of
extreme weather to stop anytime soon